So here're some of the properties
of DEC_POMDPs that probably worth
knowing about.
As you pointed out,
there's elements of game theory and
POMDPs mixed together deliciously.
And as a result,
member POMDPs, well like I told
you the POMDPs are not computable.
So DEC-POMDPs are also not computable,
but in the finite horizon, POMDPs are P
space complete which is probably
definitely kind of hard.
DEC-POMPDPs are actually known
to be NEXP-complete which is
non-deterministic.
It's like NP except with
an X in the middle,
non-deterministic exponential
time complete.
>> That sounds difficult.
>> Yeah, I mean so the best that we
know how to solve non-deterministic
exponential time problems
is double exponential time.
The shortest that it could possibly be
solvable is single exponential time.
[LAUGH] So it's somewhere between
single and double exponential.
>> Like 1.2 exponential.
>> Well, it could be, could be 1,
could be 2, could be 1.8.
>> As long as we have choices.
>> One of the the beauties of this
model, one of the reasons that people in
spite of this computational challenge,
like to think about it, is because,
just like POMDPS are useful because
they let you think about actions to gain
information, DEC POMDPS let you
think about actions to communicate.
An optimal solution to a DEC POMDP has
to balance the cost of communicating
with the cost of not communicating.
So is it worth saying this at time?
>> Okay, that makes sense.
That sounds like some of the other
discussions about POM DPs, and
exploration versus
exploitation trade offs.
>> Right.
But it gets into some of these
interesting questions
about communication.
So this is model that's fun to think
about if you're a multi-agent person or
maybe a natural language person or
a met natural language dialogue person
where you actually have to reason
about what's worth saying.
>> Okay.
>> And there are some algorithms and
heuristics that are known,
there are some applications
that are known and
just the last thing I want to do is
run us through a quick example, so
you can have a concrete example,
what it feels like to be in a DEC POMDP.
>> Okay.